[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the dursleys
harry potter's cruel and unusual
adoptive
i use that term loosely family when
harry's parents were murdered on october
31st
1981 the decision was made that harry
would be raised by his aunt petunia
and her family though they hated any and
all things magical
and were perhaps the antithesis of the
sort of family that should adopt harry
they were the safest option when lilly
died she cast a loving sacrifice
protecting harry and the sacrifice lived
on in her sister
as long as harry could call the home of
the dursleys his own
then he was safe the dursleys were also
massively critical of harry
they didn't like anything that was out
of the ordinary and all of a sudden
petunia was faced with raising her
magical young nephew
almost immediately they were hard on him
and showed clear and obvious favoritism
toward their actual son dudley they
forced harry to live in a cupboard under
the stairs
tried to prevent him from attending
hogwarts and had always hit harry's past
from him
while he did eventually end up attending
hogwarts thanks to hagrid
and was able to get away from them for a
good portion of the year
he did still have to return to their
tormentous home year
after year he really didn't have a
choice he would have to return there
until he was finally old enough that his
mother's loving sacrifice
would serve him no more this is one of
the primary reasons
that harry never went to live with the
weasleys where he was provided with a
much
more caring and nurturing environment so
year in year out
harry returned to their home out of
necessity but when we get to the final
book
film the deathly hallows a bit of a
shift occurs
this is for two reasons number one harry
is now 17 years old
meaning the loving protection from his
mother is no longer present
and number two the wizarding world is in
complete and utter turmoil
with the danger even spilling over into
the muggle world
harry who knows that the dursleys will
be targeted eventually explain to them
that their lives are in danger
the order is sure voldemort will target
you whether to torture you to try and
find out where i am
or because he thinks by holding you
hostage i'd come and try to rescue you
you've got to go into hiding and the
order wants to help you're being offered
serious protection
the best there is but vernon dursley
doesn't take this news lightly
and vehemently questions both harry's
proposition as well as the danger that
he's in
i thought there was a ministry of magic
asked vernon desley abruptly
there is said harry surprised well then
why can't they protect us it seems to me
that as innocent victims guilty of
nothing more than harboring a marked man
we ought to qualify for government
protection harry laughed
he could not help himself it was so very
typical of his uncle
to put his hopes in the establishment
even within this world that he despised
and mistrusted
you heard what mr weasley and kingsley
said harry replied
we think the ministry has been
infiltrated this eventually leads to the
jerseys
leaving their beloved home number four
privet drive
in search of a new safer and more secure
location
it's the end of an era as they bid
goodbye to the famous home
the original house with the bedroom
under the stairs but
where do they go next what is next in
store for the dursleys
what happens to them after the fall of
voldemort and the end
of the second wizarding war
interestingly enough very little is
revealed about the dursleys
after they pack up and head off however
there is a segment from the book
and a deleted scene in the film that
sort of suggests that there may be a
future
for harry and dudley the scene depicts a
moment of redemption for dudley
who in an effort to make things right
with harry shakes his hand
just before they depart harry's bully
the boy who tormented him for years
finally made an effort to set things
straight and this single act did wonders
for their relationship
in the years to come in fact it is later
revealed by rowling
that despite dudley's years of abuse
towards harry
they were later on christmas card terms
as he grew older
dudley developed into a decent man very
much unlike
the tyrannous force of nature that he
embodied in his youth
dudley even eventually got married and
had a family of his own
raising two muggle children harry and
dudley would still see each other enough
to be on christmas card terms
but they would visit more out of a sense
of duty and sit in silence
so that their children could see their
cousins this suggests that they were
never quite
friends but certainly cordial to one
another perhaps stemming from the mutual
respect
that they gained for one another in
later life as for vernon and petunia
it seems as though harry may not have
seen them again as their relationship
was never particularly good
though petunia certainly harboured
affection for harry deep within
she never made the same attempt the
deadly maid to reconcile with him
which was likely the reason for them
never reconnecting it's also been
suggested that
after the fall of voldemort the dursleys
were simply escorted back to their home
in lunging where they remained
for the rest of their lives but what do
i think happened to the dursies
i think that after the chaos that was
the wizarding wall
the dursleys would have wanted to travel
far far away
vernon had been working at grunings for
30 years at that point
and i think that this unique
circumstance may have presented him with
a good opportunity
to retire vernon was always awful to
harry and that never changed
he disliked the boy or boy as he would
frequently call him
and i'm sure that he had no desire to
see harry after the war had ended
though petunia treated harry in a
similarly awful fashion
i think the deep down she did truly care
for harry
however even if she did want to go and
visit him she would never
as it could potentially reveal to vernon
that she actually cared for him to some
extent
at the end of the day the dursleys
relished in everything that was normal
predictable and easy and i don't think
that they would have been able to look
at number four privet drive in the same
way ever again
or little whinging for that matter it
was the same place that their house was
assaulted with letters
and where their son was attacked by
dementors harry had finally moved out
and they no longer had to care for him
but so much had happened in that house
and i think that this may have been a
good opportunity for them to simply
start
anew elsewhere as i anticipate that
vernon retired at this stage
i can completely imagine the jersey
family or at least vernon and petunia
retiring in some tropical climate
sitting on the beach complaining
and drinking pina coladas vernon's safe
predictable job
as director at grannings who made drills
would have allowed him to save up just
enough money
to buy a beachfront property on an
island like mjorka
allowing him to live in a tropical
climate but with access to all the uk
food and drink with which he was
familiar
one other thing that's worth mentioning
and i'm not saying that it's canon
is that in the cursed child it suggested
that petunia actually died at some point
before harry's son began attending
hogwarts
this is when dudley returns harry's
blanket to him the same blanket that he
was wrapped in when he was left
at number four privet drive this is the
last thing i had from my mum
the only thing i was given to the
dursleys wrapped in it
i thought it had gone forever and then
when your great-aunt petunia died hidden
amongst her possessions
surprisingly dudley found this and he
kindly sent it on to me
and ever since then well anytime i've
wanted luck
i found it and just tried to hold it
this tells us that by the time albus is
a third year
petunia had actually died which is
tragic in a weird sort of way
given that she'd likely never revealed
her true affection for harry
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think happened to the dursleys
did vernon and petunia ever reconnect
with harry or had that chapter simply
closed
let me know down in the comments section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you